hola veamos si podemos utilizar la
integración por partes para encontrar la
anti derivada de la x por coseno de x de
x y siempre que hablamos de integración
por partes decimos bien pues cuál de
estas funciones funcionaría mejor para
trabajar con ellas dicho producto cuál
de estas funciones de la x y cocinó de x
nos darán a integrar más simple en este
caso a ninguna de las dos la hace más
simple pero tampoco la hace más
complicada entonces veamos que podemos
deducir o podemos tratar con esta
integral así que aquí tenemos una
especie de posibilidad para asignar una
función fx que sería a la x en este caso
y g prima de x o la derivada
a coseno de x entonces fx será igual a x
y f prima de x es igual a x a la x
recuerda que cuando tenemos la derivada
de a la x queda igual y por este lado g
prima de x de igual cosa de x e
integrando g primera para obtener que
simple sería el seno el seno de x y bien
ahora se apliquemos la integración por
partes esto va a ser igual a efe fx por
gd x que en este caso fx es a la equis y
quebec y sería seno de x por seno de x
menos la integral de f prima de x que
vuelve a hacer a la x
gx que es el seno de x seno de x
de x por supuesto y bien podríamos
observar esto y decir pero esto no nos
ha dado ningún tipo de progreso antes de
nuestra integral pues tenemos algo como
similar multiplicando aquí dos funciones
una vez más pues de hecho nos volverá a
aparecer a la equis pero en este caso
multiplicando hace 9 x de equis pero
podemos hacer esta integral
separadamente y tendríamos lo siguiente
volvemos a asignar a fx como a la x fm
de que sea la x tratando de omitir un
poco lo que hicimos anteriormente pues
no va a ser exactamente lo mismo estamos
re asignando las variables o las
funciones f primera b x vuelva a ser la
x v x sería igual al seno de x y
entonces ya una vez que tenemos esto por
aquí a no disculpa no sería gx iguala
seno de x más bien g prima de x o la
derivada de g
es igual perdón al seno de equis y ahora
sí si integramos ésta
la integral de s 9 x es igual al menos
coseno de x y pues una vez más volvemos
a aplicar la integración por partes por
lo que tenemos que fx por gd x en este
caso sería a la x x - coseno dx entonces
vamos a dejar de frente el signo
negativo y ahora si tendríamos menos sea
la x por coseno de x
menos la integral de f prima de x por gd
x x f prima es la x que prima eje x
perdón sería el coseno de x y podemos
sacar el signo negativo de nuestra
integral por lo cual ahora en lugar de
estar restando estaríamos sumando la
integral y por supuesto todo está toda
esta integral de x y después de esto
volvemos a decir otra vez no parece que
hayamos tenido algún tipo de progreso
pues de hecho estamos obteniendo ahora
otra vez la integral que teníamos en un
inicio pero podemos hacer algo
interesante con esto veamos qué ocurre
si retrocedemos a esto sustituyamos esta
cosa de por aquí que aparece que aparece
bueno no pongamos todo más bien esto que
tenemos aquí es lo mismo que tenemos en
nuestra integral original
entonces para obtener esta integral
original de la izquierda pongamos esto
de por aquí vamos
esto de aquí que acabo de encerrar que
es el resultado de dicha integral a
nuestra integral original entonces
reescribiendo lo del inicio la integral
de a la x por el seno de x anotamos este
inicio que vendría siendo hoy a la x por
el seno de x menos toda esta parte de
aquí abajo pero si te das cuenta esta
parte de aquí abajo inicia con algo
negativo entonces en lugar de ser menos
esto sea más tendríamos por aquí más y a
la equis por el coseno de equis y este
menos con la suma de esta integral se
vuelve un menos la integral menos la
integral
y a la equis
por el coseno dx de x y esto realmente
es interesante pues recordando todo lo
que hemos hecho hasta ahora es tomar
esta parte de aquí y dijimos que nuestra
integración por parte se estaba luciendo
de nuevo como lo que tenemos por acá en
un inicio por lo que podemos pasarlo
para el otro lado o más bien sumar de
ambas partes la integral de esta por lo
tanto obtendríamos acá dos veces la
integral que teníamos en un inicio al
pasar la está del otro lado y bien ahora
sí sumando de ambas partes de la especie
de ecuación que tenemos por aquí tenemos
la integral de a la x coseno de xx y
también de este lado y simplemente
realizamos nuestra suma entonces como
vemos de este lado nos queda dos veces
la integral
x x b x igual a la suma de estos dos que
simplemente se quedan de la misma forma
así que vamos a copiarlos y pegarlos por
aquí abajo los pegamos y simplemente
esta parte de acá se nos cancela y ahora
podemos resolverlo para la expresión
original de nuestra integral de la x por
el coseno de x de x pero podemos dividir
de ambos lados tal cual como si fuera
una ecuación esencial entre dos así que
si dividimos de este lado entre dos
simplemente nos va a quedar nuestra
integral inicial y del otro lado nos va
a quedar la suma de estas dos
expresiones sobre dos y ahora debemos de
ser cuidadosos pues tenemos la integral
de nuestra expresión y es única y
recuerda que simplemente utilizamos lo
que sabemos
respecto al integrar por partes y todo
esto lo podemos regresar y revisar si
está bien hecho pero también no
olvidemos aquí poner nuestra constante
así que si tomamos la integral de todo
esto
independiente podemos obtener la
integral de la x por el coseno de x que
de hecho me parece una expresión
bastante linda